da haben wir an der kanadischen küste
entlang haben und land vorbei danach
kann man die unglücksstelle es ist auf
dem video zu sehen dass eine person
zielstrebig zur hölle geht
lange war ja wirklich ein super liebes
kind von klein auf wollte immer so eine
sanftmütige wesen was man anlage so
gemacht hat war wirklich seine
lebensfreude er war extrem vielleicht
alles erlernt und in dieser situation zu
kommen als sänger sich anerkennen zu
lassen es ist schon krass wenn jemand so
jung so bekannt wird daniel waren der
beziehung geschmerzt verträge wesen
immer präsent ist und immer irgendwie
was tut und immer sich bewegt er war der
auffälligste da weil er wusste dass die
einzige chance für ihn aus seiner engen
kleine umfeld herauszuholen es gab
eigentlich kaum einen tag an dem nicht
deutlich nach alkohol gerochen hat er
wirkte verändert und so wie auch
unglücklich da war immer ein typ der
über probleme nie so gesprochen hat aber
natürlich gab es auch im privatleben
ruhige momente der zweisamkeit genossen
er ist auch ein bisschen zu gute kommt
ich hätte niemals für möglich gehalten
dass er wirklich da plant mit so einer
geschlechts angleichung zu machen und
auch ohne diese psychose entstanden ist
ist er dann plötzlich dann mit dieser
frage geschichte und das war vorher nie
der fall wir hätten ihm zur seite stehen
können wir das ist nicht so einfach so
eine hormontherapie das bringt den
ganzen körper durcheinander und schlägt
auch auf die psyche so der ursprüngliche
wir planen
da wurde er nie wieder
[Musik]